you keep a list of the worst CEOs of
every year and Dov Charney is number one
actually he hit hit number two this year
okay and I guess it's well-deserved for
all sorts of all sorts of reasons
personal activities stock price down 80%
well his personal activities are well
documented what did he do wrong at the
company so at the company you have you
have an entrepreneur that actually
deserves a lot of credit for building a
very successful thriving business and
then he kind of decided to be mr. micro
manager which you know a lot of founders
they have a lot of difficulty making
that transition yeah and then he had
virtually every store manager called him
directly one-on-one and you can't just
manage an organization that way and at
one point they had a warehousing problem
he slept on a mattress in the warehouse
with a walkie-talkie on his chest so he
was available to fix any problem that's
not CEO behavior it's not something we
teach at the tech school well here's the
thing when everything was going one
seems to her sales at American Apparel
were going up then all this
micromanaging was okay what he was doing
his personal picadillo it was okay no
one really gave it a second thought it's
when things go downhill that it's an
issue yeah so yeah again when you're a
small when you're a smaller company
micromanagement is not necessarily a
terrible thing it's when you cross the
line and you have to grow and you got to
have you got a management talent around
you and he had a revolving door some
really capable people were coming in and
they lasted a matter of months usually I
think it's interesting that some
executives at American Apparel have now
appealed to bring him back because he is
inseparable from the brand his personal
brand of sleaze is tied into American
Apparel's appeal and so I think that's
okay we put him on the cover of
Businessweek as the fall of the sleeves
King I'm just quoting Businessweek
that's all I'm doing but I mean a lot of
companies have this transition where one
person with a vision creates something
and then and then can't turn it into
something larger and enduring how do you
overcome that yeah so there are success
stories as well I mean Bill Gates that
did pretty well Steve Jobs did pretty
bad and then he did pretty well okay
what do you need to do you have to be
willing to give up a little bit of
control and that is a hard Mark
Zuckerberg
yeah delegated controlling with Sandburg
yeah and that's a world-class manager
how do you teach delegation delegation
requires trust and self-confidence more
than anything else if you don't trust
the people that are working for you you
don't have any chance to do it you have
to have an interior feel of letting you
know and you have to be self-confident
to let it go that's the kind of the
paradox in the whole thing what does
Twitter need to let Dick Costolo go he's
also on the list of your worst CEOs for
24 yeah Twitter I have mixed feelings as
I use it I think it's a great app but
it's a company that is not fulfilled its
potential and the problem with them is
they've got the Facebook comparison
they're losing time and time again
against that and to continue that
comparison he Dick Costolo was supposed
to be the Sheryl Sandberg he was
supposed to make everything work while
while the rest of the company
concentrated on on the community
undisrupted what did he failed to do so
this is another story we're revolving
door at the top a lot of top managers
come in coming and going changing the
strategy it's very interesting
entrepreneurial companies talk about the
pivot and and in Silicon Valley that's
kind of the first principle of business
pivot means you switch to strategy well
when you've gone public at what was it
30-some billion dollars that's a pretty
hard thing to be to be stomaching for
shareholders yeah company that did it
right Under Armour Under Armour's had an
unbelievable year Kevin Plank is the
real star started in apparel still big
in apparel but what they've done is
they've expanded to footwear
international and a big focus on women
I'm sorry before oh sorry please go
ahead please I was just gonna point out
that it's a Maryland based company
that's all I had to say continue no but
I interviewed mr. plank at length with
the support of General Electric and he
didn't go to Talk he did this off his
grandmother's touchy what James hell
fancy pants MBA people about the best
practices of a guy that started a
business off his grandmother's table so
do we did that there's a tech school or
business schools that teach
entrepreneurship actually actually a
little bit but this is a guy you can
learn from and we're gonna have case
studies on him and we're going to teach
our students about him he's expanded the
market and he's done in a very he's done
in a very effective way and Nike finally
has someone
challenged them which is really amazing
is it how did I divorce the performance
of the stock price from the performance
of the CEO because I noticed in their
best and worst list in each instance we
cited how the stock has done sure sure
well you know can't be a successful CEO
unless you've got the numbers to back
you up so it's hard to imagine someone
is really a great CEO and just can't
make the company work so there's a
natural connection to it but then you
have to go further because not every
company that has problems with their
stock price is its respond to the seals
responsible for it because it could be
an industry change it could be something
out of their control but in this case or
inaction in every one of these cases you
could track it directly to the CEO Tim
Cook the FT named an executive of the
year yeah Tim Cook has had and maybe
still has one of the toughest jobs in
the world to follow the legendary Steve
Jobs and and he's done pretty pretty
well look what's going look what's going
on with the company it's it's not gonna
be easy to keep coming up with the Nexen
Union new thing
how would you agree Janet Yellin very
quickly well it's not so I looked at
closely but she is doing I think all the
right moves in terms of presence and
communicating what she believes in all
right thank you so much sidney
finkelstein joining us from Tuck School
of Business